welcome to this special interview
episode here on collider with the writer
and creator of this new show from
Netflix called living with yourself that
stars Paul Rudd he is an Emmy
award-winning and Peabody award-winning
gentleman and I'm excited to talk to him
about this show Timothy Greenberg
welcome how are you thank you I'm good
yeah I like it I like this is a good
reaction or very chilly very relaxed
where you go I'm good not sure what the
questions are gonna get into it this is
the first thing I want to ask you about
this show is this what was it like to
get Paul Rudd to be a part of how did
Paul Rudd get involved in this and what
was what were your impressions after
finishing working with him on this
season I mean it was like a dream come
true to have him do this you know years
ago long before we had any reason to
think that Paul Rudd would do this I was
just a guy writing this thing in my
bedroom right um he and then you know
once we started to think who might be
good for it he was at the top of our
list and then it was many years until
there was even a chance that we might be
able to get him you know once basically
we got to Netflix and you know the high
profile and the money that they have
well he was the first one on their list
too and we sent it to him and he liked
it and that was incredible yeah I mean
it really was pretty amazing I'm as big
a fan of his as anyone you know I've
loved him in anything so I was you know
it's perfect he really goes to a lot of
interesting new places as an actor
through yeah through your scripts
through your the the show what impressed
you the most about working with him
because I'm he's creating two completely
separate characters here I mean you know
aside from just he's a good guy which
everybody talks about he would there was
two things
obviously playing the two characters
it's very difficult challenge yeah to
remember all of which character to be
able to switch between them to make the
emotional reality of each character work
be able to convey that just with such
fluidity you know based on our
production schedule that's incredible
but like for me personally it was that I
would find
his performance I'll be sitting on set
with a hundred people around I was the
one who wrote the thing and his
performance would sometimes bring me to
tears you know or I would sometimes even
think like wow my heart is really
breaking force a new miles in the scene
in a way that I hadn't fully envisioned
and yet the way that he played it I'd be
I'd be Harper I sometimes I'd come up to
him like I I'm so sad for new miles
right now or for miles so the fact that
he was able to do that I I know it's
just a make-believe story but I just
thought he was so compelling it's
perfect casting because like miles and
we should say this the show itself deals
with this gentleman this guy named miles
he's a man struggling with his life was
going through a midlife crisis he gets a
tip to go to this spa and he discovers
that he puts $50,000 down this new
version of himself can come out what he
discovers is that the new version of
himself is a clone so now he has to in
essence have this eternal struggle that
we all have with ourselves between the
idealized version of ourselves and who
we actually are at this time in our
lives and I wonder if that was did you
write this because I know the show came
from a dream that you'd had recurring as
a child but did you write this show at
this time in your life or when you
started writing it was it to deal with
your own kind of versions of yourself
that you were struggling with are we
working on yeah during the show yeah I
don't know yeah I mean in my I found
that that question of who you are as a
person are you a good person or less
than good you know are the I are you the
idealized version or not like the stakes
were raised once I was married and had
kids you know it's one thing if you're a
jerk alone in your apartment it's it's
something else if you're anything less
than wonderful to the people that you
love right and yet ironically those are
the people that we often are less than
wonderful to you know including not just
significant other than kids but our
families you know brothers in parents
and why do we do that and so yeah it
became a really daily question for me
and and I feel like that was what was
interesting about this idea that I'd had
which is more fantastical premise but
marry that to the kinds of things that I
was struggling with every day in my real
life yeah and you can see then it comes
to
when you're watching the show began I
think that's the once again why you cast
someone like Paul Rudd because this
could easy have been a modeling show a
depressing show but actually having his
lightheartedness and his charm as he
struggles the very real emotions of
confronting the life that he's currently
living and this version of himself that
he wishes could take over his life is
fascinating to watch and as you said you
feel that sympathy for this guy you know
you make for both of them even though
he's kind of a jerk yeah half the time
most of the time in the show you still
feel sympathy for him because his
intentions are good he just is clumsy
and going about it yeah I mean I do
think I think where that's particularly
an issue is like in the first 10 minutes
or 15 minutes or so yeah before he has a
real problem to deal with he's a bit of
a mess as I saw somebody say like I
think Paul Rudd helps you a lot there
people come in with a lot of love for
Paul and so that I think that gets you
through that period until Miles who
seems like he's kind of got a lot going
for him so why is he's such a downer at
some point he's got a real problem yeah
he's really got something to deal with
personally I think at that point the
viewer you know goes along with him and
starts to empathize sympathize with his
situation but yeah God knows that Paul
helped that immensely there are so many
references you talk about this we go
along there's like Blade Runner it feels
like it's a little play around this idea
of replicants clones this Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind the city
of erasing memories or you know having
memories put back into your brain
multiplicity he'll does even a Gemini
man
yeah connection here this idea of
looking at the younger version of
yourself how how much of that did you
intentionally put into the script how
much of it was just a subconsciously
appearing as you were writing the script
well I mean the ideas not new and it
goes back to dust I a ski run or that
you know look I had that like I said I
had that nightmare as a kid you know
clearly it's something there are certain
I have certainly a lot of influences I
would say I tried not to rip off people
I didn't at all know and they were great
nice way another way
yeah I mean you can try but like you
know certainly I love eternal sunshine
people strangely don't seem to connect
it to adaptation where there is actually
- I don't know I kind of agree it feels
more tonally maybe like eternal sunshine
or a little bit yeah so and I don't even
really think of it in terms of
adaptation much although that's
obviously the better reference I saw
them the movie moon right that's another
one a couple years I don't know exactly
the timing but some time before I
started writing this and I think it
possibly reminded me of those childhood
dreams but I loved that movie and that's
another one that definitely deals with
identity and and somebody finding out
that they're not who they who they think
they are you know which for me is like a
very compelling story however you set it
up whatever science fiction premise used
to set that up I'm just fascinated by
the idea that that to some degree you
are not who you think you are and I
think that's sort of true in reality in
our daily lives but just in that what fo
what if turns out I am a clone or that I
am something else like that's my story
that I I love and it's terrifying to me
well then I think that's why the show
works so well because it works on
multiple levels if you've done any kind
of psychotherapy or therapy or any kind
of exploration of of yourself the show
speaks to you very well because this
idea of the idealized version and then
the current version but the idealized
version is just what you think is right
but that doesn't mean it works for
everyone else one of the two that my
favorite scenes in the show are with
Mouse's wife kate is played by a Aisling
be the scene in the bathroom when she
says to him like you're just too perfect
you're everything's just so right about
you and we think if I just adjust these
things that I'll get loved all over
again
I will change everything but the truth
is the muck and the mire of the
relationship is the foundation of the
relationship it isn't just always in the
happy times that you find the true
connection yeah I mean I think they're
shared even though shared suffering
provides a basis exactly and yeah
anybody who's too perfect isn't that fun
to hang around you know I mean
the people that you want to hang around
with are the ones who have a sense of
humor the ones who have a sense of humor
usually the ones that are going through
something you know yeah I just that with
from those scenes I just kind of
imagined what would you be like if you
had no fear which i think is kind of a
trick with miles if you had an
experience directly mmm the pain of life
yeah you have the same memories but I
think it's different to experience the
have been there to really at some deep
level have suffered yeah and so I think
the kind of person that hasn't gone
through that would be a bit annoying you
know I do think that well Aston Villa
just mentioned she is such a standout in
the show yeah and to me she's the one
that like of course you know what you
get with Paul Rudd but Ashley B is the
reason to watch this show cuz she has to
carry dealing with this idea right and
of course miles keeps accusing her as if
she's making about herself but she is
the one that is the most of the focus
for both of these guys throughout the
show how did you go about getting her
onto the job she gave cast like what was
the situation with Ashley you know I
think a casting or casting director okay
so you never worked with her before
no and right away you know we looked at
a lot of people a lot of good actresses
like I was really humbled by the fact
that all these actresses I was really
big fans of we're reading these scenes
of mine I also was wincing at some of
the dialogue on okay I got to rewrite
that some of them actually did some
things I was like I'm gonna steal that
thank you very much and and then Ashley
who I'd never heard of I think she like
self literally self tape like had it on
a phone or something well and she just
she just killed you know and I think
what we saw in that initial you know
self tape of hers on one scene we see in
the show and I mean Elsa that scene the
one she did wasn't particularly funny so
soon as you know we went right to the
internet and started investigating her
turns out she's a comedian so I watched
everything she had done and then I went
and watched all of her previous stuff um
yes she was she's great and yeah I
really do think so yeah and to be honest
like it we knew
with she was doing great on set but it
wasn't until we cut it all together that
I went wow this she is I remember I
emailed her going like I don't you
haven't seen any of this yet but telling
you you are really fantastic in this did
you go like good job good job guys via
email but yeah what I think one of the
other things that this film really I
mean the show rather really explores
this day is this idea of mental health
and depression did you have any idea of
bringing in a psychiatrist character or
if they're like Paul I'm sorry Myles
being in the middle of this therapy
session or middle of therapy and then
this being like just this desperate
attempt to deal with it in some extreme
way
well I answered part of your question
first and I'll continue I do kind of
recall now that you mention it that's in
some really early version yeah I had
like a psychiatrist and then each of the
different she would run into I think the
different characters and not know that
they were different and she was really
freaking out about how this person had
such different personalities and was
really causing a problem for her I don't
remember the whole story but it's pretty
funny it just felt like it was it was
too far off right um but you know I've
now seen because I've been reading some
of the Twitter responses from people and
it's interesting people talk about how
this is a good metaphor for or a story
about anxiety or depression I didn't
think of it in terms of mental health
well I thought of it in terms of my life
therapist many years ago for a couple
months maybe it's time for a revisit I
don't know but I get it I mean like look
clearly miles is depressed
yes beginning um he is and and you know
I think a lot of depression and maybe
anxiety I don't know but like is about
self-loathing mm-hmm you know anger at
yourself that I know a lot about and and
so I think the
you know I'm again I'm not a
psychiatrist but I think that there's a
real connection there and it's
interesting that I did not have that in
mind but the fact that people are
getting that you know I guess shows that
we're all a lot alike yeah someone who's
been through it and I had to you know I
was seeing two therapists to climb out
of it when I headed in 2016 I found a
lot of what Paul was doing I'm sorry
miles was doing in the show very
reminiscent of some of the thought
patterns and ideas that had this idea
once again will you spoke about earlier
this idea of how do people see us how do
we see ourselves and people's
expectations of us and our behavior and
the pressures like well if I just do
whatever they tell me to do will I
really be myself and will I really be
happy being this other thing right and I
think that's what Myles explores so well
in the show is this okay
I even when he gets the chance to do
what he wants to do he hasn't addressed
the problem even when he gets to sit
around and you know watch porn and and
do what I watch dog videos or whatever
and start to write he's still not happy
even though he's doing everything he
wants to do why because he's missing out
on these other pieces of his life that
that are essential to make him happy as
well he's not addressing the core issue
which is what is the depression usually
stems from is that you're not addressing
the core issue you just papering over
the cracks yeah and the creation of the
Myles clone is papering over the cracks
yeah and so I love how your show
explores how they battle for you
physically and verbally throughout the
series yeah I mean I think that's
exactly right I think I think that um
you know we have this idealized version
of who we are and our failure to live up
to that can cause us to beat ourselves
up yeah you know and can cause us to
hate ourselves sometimes and so I that's
kind of this is the the real-world
version of that is what if there were
another you in the world how would that
make you feel right now like I don't
think it would make you feel that great
to see this better version of you now
actually have to live up to and it's
only when Myles starts trying to live up
to it and you know somewhat I guess in
competition
bit more just he's doing these things
because he feels like these are the
things that he wants to do you know Ryan
like yeah I mean the thing that makes
you happy is not having you playing
video games and sitting around it's
doing something positive
whether it's achieving something or
we're doing something positive for
someone you love or in the world like
those are what make you feel better
scientifically proven you know you go
out and do good things for other people
you will feel better and if you sit
around and act selfishly and just play
video games and order pizza while
somebody else is going to you know go do
the good things in the world for you you
will be unhappy that's ween it we know
that and science shows that yeah yeah
the other thing you explore throughout
the show is Kate's journey here as well
because she is dealing with the
disappointment of this marriage and we
do go back in time and see the
miscarriage and how that affected their
relationship we don't see fully why
miles is in this condition at this time
and I think that's why once again why
you cast him like Paul because Paul
brings all those levels in as you're
watching him but like her journey to is
her journey of discovery where she wants
to what's gonna make her happy
right and so much so that she even goes
on that douchey guys website and creates
the profile for differ dater and
actually ends up having this meeting
with the clone miles but she's trying to
break out of this rut in her own way as
well without taking the extreme choice
yeah were you very conscious to make
sure that that story was just as as
powerful in its own way yeah absolutely
I mean I think one of the main themes
call it that I really like about the
show and I haven't heard people talk
about as much as the idea perspective
yeah you know what if there were you
know I had Telesur like I've got a
friend who's always yelling at other
people in traffic you know get out of my
witty cutting me off for like I
guarantee if there were him in the other
Lane
he'd be like what is this it yelling at
me for it you know and so the idea that
there's two of you
and yet you still conflict what does
that mean I think that has to do with
our perspective and where we're coming
from in our day in our situations as far
as as far as Kate Ashe things character
though
I think I very consciously and this is
why you know ash what one of the things
that a challenge that Aisling had and it
makes her so great is you have to go
through a number of episodes before you
really get to see her perspective yes
and we very consciously were building up
the desire and the audience to see her
perspective you know so that by the time
he gets here like oh right I want to
know what's going on with her and it
turns out it's a lot more than the
audience has been aware of or that
either the miles is have been aware of
right and I think that's a major theme
for me and I also you know ashing talks
about how one of the things she likes
about the character is that yes look I
think that that the characters in some
ways sort of stronger and maybe smarter
and in some ways better than then miles
but she's got real problems too you know
some of those as Ashley has pointed out
like some of her her strengths are also
her downfall you know that she's funny
but she uses that that that comedy to
kind of create a distance between people
instead of really dealing with things
you know and so I think I think that's
true for the character and yeah I mean I
think I think actually
she's got a ways to go I mean in the
imaginary world of what happens after
these characters continue on I feel like
that her character actually has a lot to
deal with that hasn't been dealt with
you know yeah I think you drop a lot of
seeds throughout the show that I look
forward to a second season a third
season if it continues and you have
enough people watching and I mean you
all and you want to write it you know I
mean also don't forget that guys got a
lot going on yeah like you know first TV
thing like yeah he was very clear from
the outset he likes stories they're arcs
he very intentionally never wanted to do
TV that goes on and on you know and I
agree with him like I like a story that
has an ending I don't want to watch the
enough end season and go like I have to
get off wait a year for this thing to
come and then you have to kind of
reconnect it like I like having an arc
you know I always thought I would make
movies and then TV kind of sort of in
the intervening years kind of got more
towards you know cinematic style style
storytelling I also think though that
like and it's only kind of lately that
that I've really
kind of really internalize this like the
whole idea of seasons seems a little
outdated in the streaming world you know
I mean also in the world where we have
all these anthologies you know American
Horror Story not that I've seen it but
it's about something different every
year you know or I mean even the wire
kind of started it where they switch
yeah that was great like I feel like I
just feel you know I don't know I'm not
saying that to think of any future
things it's like a sequel because that's
not quite right either but I you know
maybe it's a you know there are chapters
in a book that are each episode and then
there's a book and then maybe there's
another book in the series the idea of
seasons is like feels to me like sort of
is somebody writing it a little outdated
yeah I understand that because we're
transitioning into a new world yeah I
mean one thing and people watching more
British stuff and British stuff is like
three episodes an hour and a half yeah
so like Luther yeah and you're done with
this yeah this season yeah yeah
obviously that's different for different
kinds of shows sure certain kinds of
shows it totally makes sense or even to
some extent again I haven't seen the
second seen stranger things but I watch
you know like some of those you kind of
you get it uh yeah whereas just for me
personally I feel like it's a little bit
of an outdated way of thinking about it
for making a show like this yeah
there's a lot there's a running subplot
here there's a lot of symbolism
throughout the show which I really
enjoyed him in the opening thing of him
climbing out of the pit the burial pit
which is in essence we find out later
it's actually him miles climbing out of
trying to climb out of his own life
this old that essentially was burying
him as well the flies thing which
essentially kind of infer these walking
dead the credenza we mentioned
off-camera the credenza of course being
part of the symbolism as well but one of
the big some that I thought was
interesting that is ironic is that you
have this running subplot as we discover
throughout the show that they want to
have a baby they want to create a life
and here is the life that they have in
essence kind of accidentally created
which is this climb and so this balance
between this idea and now you end that
way with the course because I this is
gonna is a spoiler discussion wheat
which will say it the river that you end
this way that they now have this new
light that's coming into the situation
so we've seen sink comes of my two dads
now we've got my two dads my mom and
this is an interesting situation
this idea of a triple parentage for the
child if you do a second season are we
picking up with the child already born
in the in this or are we dealing with
the pregnancy first throughout the whole
second season I don't know what I'll say
is I thought that the situation where on
the one hand it's the best thing that
could possibly happen because it's right
it's it's what they've wanted more than
anything else other than maybe fixing
their relationship but um so it's the
best thing they could have it it's
exactly what they wanted yeah and yet
now they're stuck together right and so
even if there's even if we're not
continuing the story just the idea that
Wow
and that that final look on Kate's face
you know where this is the greatest
thing but oh how is this gonna work
exactly like I love that notion right
there tied up you know I mean it's
definitely you know this is going to be
very very tricky whatever happens from
here so I was certainly waiting to see
what the last reaction of Kate's face
was that you may linger on and then cut
I was waiting and then when you got
there as all this that's brilliant yeah
yeah I love that yeah and we even sort
of drop out the music there she can hear
her go like you understand that it's
wonderful that hold on what's gonna
happen was there any was there an
alternate ending that you were toying
around with where she doesn't and where
she divorces him or breaks up with him
or leaves for a while it takes a break
did you always feel like I had them
staying together and I always had them
staying together I like happy endings if
you want to imagine more story I I don't
you know I don't know they or not have
not dealt with a lot of things rise in
in my view you know I think it's a
strong statement though because that's
how a relationship works you know at the
end yeah there's the desire to leave
possibly at times but you also have to
take responsibility for what you've both
created and how can you climb out of it
if you want to save it and you can tell
by the end the Kate really does love
miles and it's that when he comes look
the super freak dance is everything I'm
telling you that's right right
you see their connection yeah like she's
ready to leave him sitting on the stairs
right I don't know what the what you had
written there but it seems like she's
ready to leave him and then he just says
let me just and it mirrors obviously in
a contrast when they tried to do the
dance the clone miles and her in the
restaurant because the connection she
has instinctively with the actual miles
yeah that's why they flow so well
together
yeah I thought yeah I mean I thought
both the dancing and the failed love
making scenes yeah like there is an
unconscious relationship that you have
with your partner of many years that can
be expressed in nonverbal ways you know
I mean I'm a lot of nonverbal ways that
that you only really can have that
whatever this what I'm saying there
memory transfer processes it doesn't it
doesn't go that deep yeah and I think
that there is some you know there's
something that they share that the other
mile new miles at her don't know what
choreographed that
who choreographed that scene it was
choreographer Jenny sure she was amazing
and she worked with Paul and Aisling you
know to kind of get moves that they were
comfortable with and that we that she
felt would would naturally come from the
character and she you know she read it
all and thought about who they were and
then the three of them really really
built it together yeah yeah she was
fantastic did she tell you who who
learned the stuff quicker no I mean I
think it was clear because we did kind
of watch some of the hearses they were
going along okay they were both good
dancers we've all seen Paul dance in the
teen videos and other things yeah Ashley
as soon as she started moving you can
tell somebody's a good dancer like
immediately right as soon as she did a
few steps like alright great she's a
good dancer too the scenes gonna work
were there any as you get a rep up here
in the next couple of minutes but as you
were writing as you were going through
shooting these episodes and being you
know obviously writing everything did
you make any changes to the script as
Paul and Ashley talked about in an
audition process your re-editing and
whatever as you were watching them read
your lines but is there anything as you
were making the show that you change
story line wise that was really
important I don't think so I don't know
we had that luxury
because we were shooting it all out of
order and it's a pretty tight jigsaw
puzzle you know for production you
sometimes got a chain things you didn't
get the scene or you didn't finish it in
this way so how are we gonna deal with
that so there was some of that and
honestly I don't even recall what it was
but yeah you're doing it more for
production not because we were learning
things about the show itself I think
okay yeah and one last question here
what what now climbing out of this in
essence climbing out of your own burial
pit of this what's your experience
walking away from this show what's your
experience and now that it's on now that
it's out what did you like discovery by
yourself or learn about yourself Myles
what did you been a lot going on this
week if the premiere and the press
coverage and everything else right I've
learned it I'm still both the better and
worse versions of myself
it never stops it never stops yeah you
know that's who we are
yeah doesn't matter where you are in
life you know we are both are better and
worse cells yeah yeah there you go and
that's I think that's a great weight and
we're both are better than our worst
selves and this show absolutely explores
that in hilarious ways but also a very
meaningful way so if you haven't seen
living with yourself please do yourself
a favor watch this show Thank You
Timothy greenberg for stopping by to
talk with us it was really awesome thank
you so much yeah that's my pleasure man
all right see this thing on Netflix
remember like and share this video on
your social media and subscribe to
Collider for more interviews just like
this and we'll talk to you soon